hey leute was geht ist es dienstagmorgen
11 uhr und ich habe mir überlegt wie so
trinkst du nicht mal 24 stunden lang nur
kaffee wie ihr vielleicht wisst habe ich
hier mein bild wie meine kaffeemaschine
erstmal für dieses wunderschöne gerät
ein kleiner kaffeemaschinen wir müssen
wissen so ein ding ist nicht ganz
günstig und ich habe lange überlegt ich
mir die verschiedene geholt hat und
mittlerweile ist es wirklich jeden
morgen mit freude ich trinke gar nicht
so viel kaffee meisten strings so ein
zwei tassen am tag aber mit dieser
maschine ist wirklich cup hier noch mal
was ganz anderes man kann diese coole
latte art herzen reinach das werde ich
heute auch noch jede menge darüber
erzählt prinzip wollte ich eigentlich
auch nur ein video wird die
kaffeemaschine machen aber ich würde
sagen wir fangen an mit dem ersten
kaffee es geht nämlich gleich um 11 uhr
30 in die uni dann muss man dafür erst
mal kaffee trinke ich werde mich jetzt
einmal das prozedere zeigen wie ich
immer meinen kaffee macht das vielleicht
ein bisschen übertrieben aber ich habe
das selbst in einem café youtuber
gelernt den verlinkt ich auch mal weil
das echt cool besser aus deutschland ich
liege zunächst mal einen kaffee in dem
ich diese kleine es presse kann und
nehme
13 51 plätze
die boden sind hier oben drin und wenn
man die frisch präparierten neben jetzt
und füllen ihn in dieses sieht ein weil
das ist eine siebträgermaschine die
heiße reifen so super ist der kaffee
kommt anspannung an den siebträger ein
und kann man mit sehr hohen druck den
kaffee extrahieren okay das heißt wir
fühlen uns presse jetzt mal im zib 1
und dann geht es darum dass man im café
einmal android mit ein bisschen kraft
und möglichst gleichmäßig spannende
verein weitere 1
jetzt schaue ich auch das ist auch
relativ schwierig das sieht vielleicht
alles einfach aus und wenn es dann ein
bisschen zu heiß wird es heißer
wasserdampf um es mit der hand an zu
packen darf man es abnehmen jetzt ist es
so weit ich werde es wahrscheinlich
verpacken ich mir noch gar nicht so gut
darin aber jetzt geht es darum die latte
art zu machen das heißt dieses kleine
kunstwerk in die milch hinein
beschreiben ob ich komplett verkauft
naja ok das ist nicht richtig gut aber
vielleicht noch was besseres hin ein
kleines heer ist und damit würde ich
sagen würde die erste tasse kaffee ich
bin nicht sicher ob das gesundheitlich
unbedenklich ist was ich hier vor habe
aber ich rede erst 24 stunden dann nur
kaffeetrinken disco ich weiß nicht auf
die nächsten kaffeetassen auch alle so
gut schmecken werden aber ich möchte
jetzt erstmal da geht es in die uni
der erste cup jetzt leer dass das erste
mal seitdem kelly video dass ich wieder
so ein bisschen blogger und irgendwie
war unglaublich spaß vielleicht mal das
jetzt öfter wir sind auf dem weg in die
uni super trinkt etwas was mir hier sehr
gut
wasser ist das wasser luca um ein girlie
ekelerregend ich trinke nur knappe
viertelstunde trumpften fest ein
aber ich habe auch erst um 11 uhr
angefangen guten tag willkommen zum
besten video des jahres
licon abonnieren und kommentieren jetzt
raus aus der unis eine stunde später
wir haben nur eine kleine projekt
besprechung gehabt ich habe es ja nur
eine tasse kaffee getrunken und
irgendwie hätte ich jetzt bot wasser zu
trinken aber da ich ja nicht und ich
glaube ich muss jetzt schon anfangen mir
das ein bisschen einzuteilen weil wenn
ich den ganzen tag nur kaffee trinken
darf da muss ich halt den kaffee
wahrscheinlich besser so ein bisschen
verdünnen aber wir gehen jetzt essen das
heißt ich kann wahrscheinlich nicht ein
café mit einem halben liter milch
bestellen schauen wir mal wie gene jetzt
hin
ich glaube den typisch ist das heißt ich
kann erstmal jetzt türkischen kaffee
trinken essen bestellt und ich habe dass
man eingestellt
aber da hab ich ja gar nicht es gebe ich
davon zu essen das ist der ehrenwerte
spender niemand dankt er auch niemals
nacken alle haben was zu trinken aber es
gab einfach keinen kaffee nichts zu
trinken für mich belastet mega belasten
aber lasst ihr so schmecken ich habe
dann gleich
[Musik]
ich muss jetzt schauen wo ich mir was zu
trinken sollen ich hätte mir auch ein
espresso in iran machen können trinken
ist pressesprecher jan muss das sein was
press zum mitnehmen und das wwe
universum kleine ist wasserstoff mit dem
füttern die bereits mir ist aufgefallen
dass hier mit meiner nur ganz gut
schmecken kann was ich mein herz schlapp
und so und das wird mal ein bisschen
überwachen kann deshalb nur herzfrequenz
heutigen sechs schläge pro minute steht
sind 98 meine ich sitze schon die ganze
verliert und mache eigentlich nicht
bösartig was wir mal gespannt das muss
ich auf jeden fall im blick halten und
meinen herzschlag hoch bedeutet das
haben jetzt erstmal die karriere macht
ins geschäft bleibe ich keinen
herzfehler das ist schon mal gut ich
meine ich habe auch bisher nur einen
kaffee getrunken deshalb muss jetzt auch
endlich mal wieder was trinken wir sind
jetzt noch mal einen laden weiter
gegangen und erst jetzt von backwaren
satz zu trinken kaffee und von ihm
stammt er endlich von zwei cafés leer
gewesen und habe jetzt mein herzrasen
gefühl sie jetzt habt ihr nach hause weg
und ich bin echt mal gespannt ob das
irgendwie auswirkungen auf meine
produktivität haben wird bei kaffee ist
ja an sich so das getränk für die leute
die im büro sitzen und irgendwie energie
brauchen und sonst was vielleicht ist es
der absolute geheimtipp dass man einfach
den ganzen tag lang nur kaffee trinken
dann wird man so produkt ich bin wieder
zu hause meine kaffeemaschine ist auch
am start ich habe jetzt einen kleinen
café machen und ein bisschen am video
weiter spannen ich habe nämlich gerade
schon angefangen so sieht das hier
ausschnitte nämlich immer auf meinem her
weil das ist das einfachste ging es mal
so eine art will ich dazu dass nicht die
ganze zeit normale milch trinke und weil
jeder weiß welches gift mit eis sie
wissen bescheid dann auf dem balkon
bisschen schneiden beste leben gibt es
nicht einfach toll aus ist auch heute
schon wieder weg weil das ist wieder ein
anderer café schneider mein video du
bist sie ist der schlechte gastgeber
wird ist auch colin kürbis trinken
überleben
ich habe gerade so ein fünftel geschafft
von der zeit langsam hätte ich schon
bock auf was anderes als café aber ich
glaube so von der aufregung her und
sowas konzentrationsfähigkeit ist es
eigentlich ganz gut aktuell so ich fühle
mich jetzt nicht sonst wäre ich so
voller abgelenkt und hibbelig oder so
ich komme auch ganz gut damit aber noch
nicht so viel kaffee kommen
die stadt natürlich um einen kaffee zu
trinken und treffen
we're going to get the screen and drinks
am café gucken bis das kleine baby in
der mitte ja aber ich darf ja nur kaffee
trinken und essen aber wenn als sinken
da muss schnell wo hat ihr steht ihr
wenigstens ein bisschen besitzer richtig
bilden und aus mir steht die richtig gut
wir sind am shoppen wir sind jetzt noch
ein bisschen der stadt unterwegs und
nicht merkt langsam dass ich so ein
bisschen neben der spur stehe glaube
weil ich halt einfach zu wenig getrunken
habe ich meine ich habe auch nicht so
viel kaffee getrunken wie ich sonst
wasser trinken würde aber ich glaube
dann wäre es nur noch schlimmer aber ja
wir gehen jetzt mal in die innenstadt
gleichwertig mich immer wieder was zu
trinken also einen kaffee holen einfach
der schönen tag das schöne wetter die
herzfrequenzen die großartig geändert
ich habe von war es sogar noch mehr
langsam merkt richtig wenn dann so
richtig neben der spur aber ich glaube
sich dann dass ich zu wenig trinkt nicht
dass ich noch kaffee trinke ich muss
jetzt gleich mal wieder irgendwo ein
kaffee holen und dann komme ich klar ich
mich so voll schlecht konzentrieren und
keine ahnung leute ist längst nicht mehr
klar beginns des direkt einen kaffee
holen und ich hoffe ich dass es dann
besser wird wenn nicht muss ich
vielleicht mein experiment abbrechen
aber ich überhaupt kein bock abzubrechen
weil eigentlich es war interessant ist
aber schauen wir mal ich will mich so
als hätte ich zwei tage schlafen hier
bin ich jetzt echt voll neben der spur
ist vor kurzem ein foto
[Musik]
was denkt kapuze aus kannst dann weil
ich da gute 77 heftig einfach wollen wir
uns 100 ich habe jetzt gerade ja noch
ein kaffee getrunken heißen kaffee das
fühlt sich so verwirklichen post und
irgendwie drückt das duo auf meinen kopf
ich bin mir nicht sicher was gut ist ich
glaube sehr wahrscheinlich nicht ob ich
muss dass ich noch ein bisschen
beobachten weil wenn ich jetzt weiter
kaffee trinken das schlimmer wird kann
ich es auf jeden fall nicht durchziehen
vielleicht hatte ich davor mal googeln
so etwas passieren kann wenn man es
machen
ich glaube der kaffee sollte er so
langsam mit seiner wirkung einsetzen
aber irgendwie also erst mit wenig müde
ich habe nicht kennt und 19 uhr
und zweitens fühle ich mich so ein
bisschen als recht betrunken also dass
ich so ich weiß nicht ob wir das kennt
aber das ist so die sachen so ein
bisschen verzögert wahrnehmen und so
wird also es ist definitiv nicht der
klassische grippe infekt auto aufgesetzt
also ja ich weiß nicht so recht was
jetzt weitermachen soll und wie ich
weitermachen soll
ich warte erstmal ab wie sich das jetzt
weiterhin wirklich trinkt jetzt auf
jeden fall erstmal nicht noch ein kaffee
weil ich habe angst hat dann in diesem
fall kopfschmerzen bekommen und er neben
der spur stehe ich glaube ich muss jetzt
auch nach hause und dann recherchiere
ich mal ein bisschen was das mit einem
machtkampf die kaffee trinkt mir mal da
statt zu sagen als maxi das so durch
der fake das nicht ich werde 90 prozent
aller youtube drinnen so ist das feld
abonniert allemal denn max wird er sich
bestimmt freuen
ich verstehe warum man das faken könnte
aber jetzt erst mal weiterschauen links
das ist schön
da kam nochmal kopfschmerzen ich sitze
jetzt am laptop man hat mal die
gesundheitsrisiken von kaffee gegoogelt
und bekanntlicherweise koffein im kaffee
und das ist der stoff der auch probleme
machen kann koffein ist nämlich
eigentlich ein gift gegen insekten das
bildet die kaffeepflanze damit insekten
keinen kaffee essen aber beim menschen
wirkt es auf pushen und zwar das wisst
ihr ja die tödliche dosis für einen
menschen sind zehn gramm kokain und das
entspricht 3 133 espressi also ich muss
scheinbar schon mal keine angst um mein
leben sehr vergiftungserscheinungen
können allerdings schon ab einem gramm
koffein auftreten was immer noch 33
espressi sind was sie auch lange nicht
erreicht trotzdem können symptome
auftreten wie schlaflosigkeit unruhe
höher und sehstörungen herzrasen sowie
herzrhythmusstörungen mein herzschlag
war mein herz rhythmus habe ich ja schon
mal mit meiner uhr unter kontrolle
keine ahnung unruhe ja ich bin auf jeden
fall ein bisschen unruhig sehstörung so
weit würde ich jetzt nicht gehen aber
ich bin auf jeden fall so richtig
unkonzentriert was wir auch gerade schon
bereit
dementsprechend ist es glaube ich ich
gerade so gesund kaffee ist kann
flüssigkeit räuber das heißt es gibt ja
so den aberglauben das café flüssigkeit
entzieht das heißt wenn man kaffee
trinkt muss man erst recht viel trinken
weil er einmal flüssigkeit entzieht das
stimmt aber nicht dass ein fehlglaube
sonst hätte ich das aber auch gar nicht
erst angefangen
trotzdem ist es glaube ich nicht gesund
wenn man nur kaffee trinkt hier bin ich
ja dann schneiden das langsam muss ich
mal wieder was trinken ich werde dich
noch mal einen kaffee heranwagen der kp
erwischen wir aber schon die ganze zeit
beim gehen und so dass gerade über zehn
stunden also müdigkeit ist dadurch auf
jeden fall nicht weg sondern ich bin
eher müder als wenn ich keinen kaffee
trinke das ist irgendwie nicht so sinn
der sache und wenn ich mir das vorstelle
dass vielleicht trotzdem nicht
einschlafen kann ich ziemlich dunkel es
gibt jetzt erstmal neuen café wie wärs
denn damit verlangen
ich habe übrigens ein t shirt ist mir
heute gekocht ich habe meine kommentare
bis 3 findet ich war jetzt ein
cappuccino und ein espresso toning was
ja auch im café getränk ist deshalb
jetzt auch erlaubt also setzt gott
er ist bereit seinen cappuccino oder ist
bereits mit seinem capo verleihen
ob das was wird ich will nicht sagen
würde es ja nicht mal einen roman alters
geht aber es geht aber es sei auch nicht
richtig schön läuft ich bin echt noch
ganz am anfang meiner reise das für dich
und ich freue mich sehr
keine ahnung sollte ich habe die
maschine jetzt seit über einem halben
jahr und irgendwie werde ich auch nicht
deutlich besser in mathe hat man deshalb
wenn ihr wissen wie spät schreibt mir
auf den verkehr ein kommentar mit
welchen tipps
jetzt sehen wir auch ganz viele leute
wie ich das mache deshalb kann ich mich
da auch verbessern und ihr mehr gerade
der kaffee war irgendwie da seine
website und ich rede verdammt ja denn
beliebte café soße und aus irgendeinem
grund bin ich jetzt gerade auch wieder
nicht müde
sondern hat energie durch die zeit noch
ein kaffee zu trinken und sich weiter
das ist ja auch das zentrale ganz
deutschland wenn der seminare für seine
schultern
ich werde euch denkweise espresso tonic
ist wirklich eine sache die man in
vielen gut sortierten und kaffeehäusern
runde richtig eigentlich noch mit eis
das ist so ein sommergetränk und ich mag
es eigentlich gar nicht also ich mag das
wirklich nicht so gerne ich habe einfach
keinen bock mehr auf irgendwie trend mit
märchen ist wird es jetzt eines
pressetraining das wird es uns schmecken
das ist die klassische zubereitung sind
nicht aber man macht tatsächlich erst
den espresso und eine stop order ja das
kann man so vorkommen und so leute
trinkt man das dann täglich eine ganze
schublade
hier ist der beweis leute das ist die
neueste und hippste kaffeekreationen
trick gibt es aber auch bei diesem
kaffeegetränk schütten sie einen
espresso lanze über einen eiswürfel mit
tonic water dann schon das getränk nicht
geschnitten ist jetzt auch den eiswürfel
hier drauf hat rast und ja das hier ist
ja der ist presto nick die ziemlich
neues aus aber ich glaube ich mag es
nicht unnötig und etwas völlig so
scheiße aber ich heute nicht schon
wieder mit trinken ich habe gesagt genug
von kaffee um 22.15 uhr süßen jakob hast
eigentlich kaffee bzw
ich kann ihn nicht trinken weil er den
verdanken
also wie normaler kaffee für den außer
dass das ist tatsächlich etwas
interessantes was mich wirklich würde
ich sehr interessiert
[Musik]
ich sitze jetzt seid mal eine stunde vor
diesen espresso tonic und ich habe
einfach kein bock mehr kaffee zu trinken
sebastian ist jetzt auch gerade gekommen
was sagst du zu deinem projekt die zum
kaffeetrinken es mir vorgestellt wie das
wäre wenn ich 40 bin kapitän ich hätte
das keine lust dass ich meine uni zeit
dass man zu hause schreibt unsere fünf
café stück trinke ich keinen bock mehr
aber diese down phase habe ich jetzt
irgendwie bisschen überwunden natürlich
mit kaffee und jetzt sobald ihr seht
hier 23 uhr 2 das heißt zwölf stunden
sind geschafft zwei stunden sind ja
nicht nur die halbzeit
keiner kommt man weiter zu machen aber
ich schwöre bei allem was mir lieb ist
sich nicht getötet habt habe zwölf
stunden dann nichts anderes als kaffee
getrunken mein körper fühlt sich auch
dementsprechend ich kann es nicht
empfehlen mache es nicht nach es ist
aber eine interessante erfahrung deshalb
dokumentiert dies für euch und ihr gebt
mir dafür danke ich werde auch immer
lustiger mit jeder stunde die ich nur
kaffee trinken ideal stein irgendwie
werde ich nicht so richtig müde ich muss
aber gleich aber trotzdem probieren mich
ins bett zu legen weil ich habe echt
keinen bock mehr wach zu sein und kaffee
zu trinken ich werde vermutlich lange
schlafen und morgen um kurz vor elf
aufstehen und einfach so viel wasser
trinken
aber jetzt scheint es noch ein bisschen
und ich trinke jetzt aber auch keinen
kaffee mehr vom flachen gehen das war
für eine stunde noch oder so damit ich
dann wirklich ins bett gehen kann und
hoffentlich keine großen probleme
einzuschlafen aber meine lippen und so
werden schon ein bisschen trocken ich
mache es weiter auf meinem sofa mich in
so einem zustand zwischen müde und säure
wird kaffee gemahlin the world ist wir
haben 20 35 ich habe in der letzten zeit
überhaupt nichts mehr geraten oder 35
aber es wird natürlich kaffee getrunken
jetzt kaffeetrinker live leute ist jetzt
ein 911 die jungs und alle welt
und ich habe eigentlich voll durst aber
ich kann jetzt keinen kaffee trinken
also unmittelbar vorm schlafengehen
deshalb mache ich mir jetzt ein café für
die nacht wenn ich aufwache und
übertragung trockenen mund habe glaube
ich keine gute idee
trotzdem ist aufgefallen dass ist davon
amerikaner sondern einfach nur ein
komplett über extrahierte espresso ich
habe jetzt auch kein bock mich jetzt
einfach kennen morgen freunde
es ist jetzt ja nichts morgen ich muss
sagen dass sich überraschender weise gut
geschlafen habe ihr müsst wissen dass
ich eigentlich immer gut einschlafen
kann und wirklich ungelogen nach einer
minute weg werde ich mich abends ins
bett legen vielleicht so 10 15 minuten
gebraucht um einzuschlafen naja so zwei
drei mal wach gewordene der nacht das
werde ich sonst auch nicht unbedingt
aber der schlafe jetzt nicht wirklich so
unbedingt stören das einzige nervige war
ich hatte so einen durst in der nacht
und ich habe auch jetzt noch vor den
durst würde gerne ein glas wasser
trinken das ist auch so ein ritual ich
trinke noch mal aufstehen wenn ich hier
mal ein glas wasser und den kaffee die
nicht nur noch für die nacht gemacht hat
man wirklich haben
das wäre auch keine gute idee gewesen
glaub ich weiß eigentlich was ihr noch
welche hat gedacht habt ich habe eine
tolle zeit aus den augen verloren guckt
euch das mal an 10 uhr 59 und ich habe
einfach noch zwei stunden geschnitten
habe überhaupt nichts getrunken in der
zwischenzeit und jetzt bin ich gerade so
weit dass ich jetzt wieder ein glas
wasser trinken kann die urspring jeden
moment um und wendigkeit under also ich
bin ja fast schon ist auch gesund da ist
das okay ich mache zum das wasserrad ja
leute hier sitze ich mit meinem wasser
es sind glaube ich noch nie in den
letzten paar jahren über zehn stunden
vergangen wo ich nichts getrunken habe
ein glas wasser trick jetzt einfach was
wirklich bilden das nach kaffee schmeckt
aber es tut so gut oh mein gott leute
ich hab nichts mehr solange auch nichts
getrunken weil ich keinen kaffee vorm
schlafengehen trinken wollte gott ich
habe das gefühl wenn man so lange nur
kaffee getrunken hat hat wasser den
effekt den kaffee eigentlich hat also
mein ganzer körper ist gerade so durch
strömt von energie und
alles fühlt sich so richtig fresh an was
soll ich sagen leute es war ein sehr
interessantes projekt 24 stunden lang
nur kaffee trinken wenn ihr noch mal ein
ähnliches projekt sehen wollt dann kann
er und schreibt gern die kommentare ich
mache gern noch mal so ein test wenn
irgendwas einfältig muss dass wir jetzt
auch ganz schnell fertig machen weil es
ist jetzt elfter und das video kommt um
12 uhr ich hoffe ja dass viel spaß beim
schauen wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal
wieder und bis dahin